yeah uh hey hey guys
how y'all doing how you doing
um yeah no so we can explain what
I like to party Jesus honey this is
unwaxed
the Sophia and Sistine Salon did we just
become best friends it wouldn't be a
true unboxed podcast without our iconic
intro so if we take it away hello
everybody and welcome back to another
episode of the unwaxed podcast with your
favorite sisters Sistine and Sophia
[Applause]
that's on waxers okay
um sorry for literally curving you and
ghosting you and not giving any
explanation to why I truly went full
Houdini on you guys and just disappeared
a rabbit in a hat no question yeah out
of there and uh it was a little unfair
you know I think it was a little toxic
of us to do that leave you guys hanging
it's unwaxed so I guess it's no that
can't be our brand no no we're not toxic
but but
we are back we are shooting a new
episode we will explain everything of
why we're just so sorry we are very
sorry and we missed you guys and you
have no idea how much we missed this so
if you've been here and you've been
waiting and you've been messaging us
where the hell is on wax guys where's
your show we've ignored every message we
have because we were ashamed we were
ashamed felt disgusted in our own
behavior for just leaving you guys high
and dry so with that being said we have
been shooting a goddamn reality show
people get to see how fun and silly and
crazy our family Dynamic is and I think
everyone's gonna really enjoy it it's
been a trying time but it's been such a
journey and the payoff isn't understand
it will be and let me tell you something
but it's not a reality show I like to
call it a DocuSign but it's a reality
show because a lot of people are like oh
my God reality TV that's the worst level
of TV but it's the best source of
entertainment I'm sorry I'm sorry isn't
this kind of a reality show I thought I
heard a few of you guys online saying
and honestly this podcast was kind of
the thing that got the ball rolling with
it and we've been doing it with our
family and
here's the update
the show is going to be on Paramount
plus we have been filming this reality
show since March honestly even before
that so a little bit before that and we
have been shooting non-stop we're doing
a 10 episode season it's a lot of fun
you see our relationships play out you
see us working on our different
Endeavors I mean it's you see our family
Dynamics which everyone loves like
you've seen a little bit of it when
you've watched Our Family episodes with
our mom our dad our sister all of us
together so three months a lot has
happened in three months and Sophie and
I have been trying to figure out how can
we fit all of these things and feelings
and changes in three months into one
show which quite hard can't so we are
definitely gonna come back every week
until maybe we can keep going past 100
if we're just feeling I think we should
start with you Sophia I'm gonna put you
on the hot seat the most recent episode
he hates me for this so sorry for
bringing this up okay the most recent
episode that we released on on wax was
Sophia broke up with him yeah
um so what's your update I think the
title was a little much oh I'm so sorry
but why 4K but guys we're back together
okay did we see this coming yeah
so does she lie to all of you work well
together and I missed him and I don't
really want to keep going into this I'm
over talking about my relationship I'm
over because I jumped a gun on it I'm so
sorry we've also decided to make a major
life change we have oh Sophia and I
decided on a whim because this is how we
are quirky like that
um we decided we're moving to New York
City
okay we know that when we shot our
episodes in New York so Steve was like I
don't know I can't walk across the
street without getting hit by a car
I and Scar will lose her passport and
everything else and Sophia you know what
it was we were lying in bed together one
morning
we're sipping our coffee and I look at
her and she looks at me and she goes we
should move to New York and I said that
is the best dumb idea I've ever heard
you say and since then we're doing it we
found a place together well it was one
of these things was so serendipitous I
go okay our lease is going up
our parents don't live on the west coast
anymore everyone knows they live in the
East Coast
um
I don't have any ties to the West Coast
and I feel like especially your
boyfriend lives in New York yes and I
feel like with everything else I feel
like when you have a podcast anything in
entertainment you can kind of go to LA
or New York or Florida and that's kind
of like the Trinity but I thought we
haven't lived anywhere else I'm pressing
reset on my life we are moving to the
Big Apple baby I'm gonna be a Broadway
star
you oh yeah Bright Lights big city we
are going to tear it up I don't think
you guys the content that we're about to
give you is going to be so rich first of
all I already have a story for you
Sophia and I were just in New York right
looking at places scouting neighborhoods
that we like the whole Shabbat
Shabbat the whole Shabbat the whole
shebang you mean
not like the whole Shabbat dinner
got it right I thought you know what
whatever
I liked it anyway so um I'm walking with
Scarlett down the street
and we are just taking it all in
smelling the trash freezing our asses
off just like it's just accepting the
city
and I take a step back because I Stumble
a little bit and I thought I stepped on
Scarlet's foot and I was like oh sorry
Scarlett
but then I hear a
I heard a squeal and it's Scarlett had
the sh the most shocking horror face and
she goes oh my God and I go what and I
look down and I stepped on the biggest
rat
I think this rat ate seven rats it was
it was no Remy the Ratatouille it was a
beast yeah it was the size
[Music]
it was the size of like a small
Chihuahuas that I was insane and get
this I started freaking out going oh my
God oh my God it was a fat boy it was a
fat rat and I turned the corner to look
at it and I was like I need to see what
I just stepped on I don't know why I
didn't walk away I was very curious at
this point
I turned the corner with Scarlet we look
at the rot the rat launches at us
launches like these [ __ ] you
don't mess with no they live there
they're like these are pedestrians these
are people that are visiting the city
you guys weren't but here's the thing I
turned it into a Learning lesson The
Learning lesson is what if there's trash
on the sidewalk you cross the street
because they stay in the trash well I'm
assuming they're probably eating all the
trash that's actually a good lesson it's
a good lesson so we'll ever do it again
check checked off there's a lot of uh
there's other things that we we had
discussed about moving because when we
move we're moving together we're gonna
live together so before remember we've
had this little up and down thing we've
had living together not living together
and now we're back to living together
and let me tell you something
I'd be lying if I said I was 100
confident to live with Sophia I would be
live I said I was so confident love is
sustained because when we live together
for the first time
night one we got in the biggest
screaming fight ever we're honestly like
an old married couple we're too similar
yeah it's it's pretty bad because we
don't have a filter when you're living
with your sibling no it's really bad you
can really say like pick up the damn
trash if you're living with your friend
you can't really say that because you
don't want them to get offended but we
thought you know for safety for rent
purposes and also it makes sense like if
we lived alone in a new city it would be
a little bit intimidating it would be
um plus I think it's gonna be fun but
you know it's definitely just gonna be a
transition living back with you I don't
know see I already have um pet peeves
that I know you're gonna do so I feel
like it's best if we air them out now
yeah just so you don't do them anymore
okay
um you're really messy when you cook and
you always make the kitchen smell like
eggs and you know I don't like eggs you
also don't clean your like you don't
okay so my pet peeve is good enough but
you don't like eggs
a dishwasher magically gets full 16 you
don't clean what are you talking I
always have to put you she doesn't come
Scarlet does she clean
it's garlic to this garlic Scarlett did
not live with us
thank you she does not clean
that's another one that is
our apartment I don't want to see you've
seen me since I was a baby
at eight in the morning I don't want to
see it you'd be so lucky I have a fever
before breakfast I can't do it but first
beavers no no no no
come on okay first of all if it's my
apartment and I'm paying half I'm gonna
do what I wanna do you're not my friend
you're my sister okay so what if I just
walked around
and find all your clothes all day
you'd be pissed right
if I have this if I see pieces of
freaking black hair all around in the
bathrooms in the living rooms she sheds
like a freaking golden retriever she
doesn't pick up her black hair first of
all
you don't like my revenge color
this is pretty good you've had this
Revenge color I've been for the last 12
years because I've been scheming revenge
for the last 12 years of my life by the
way can I tell you she's upset with me
because I've been considering going
brown Sophia wants to go brunette you
guys that is so [ __ ] up you know
that's me wait first of all there's so
many other people tell Haley Bieber she
can't be brunette she's not my sister
okay Scarlets people think it's gonna be
darker people think we're twins you know
how the hell is like that one dark no
they shut up you know how there's always
like there's always that like one dark
friend in the Friendship there's like
the dark girl like the black hat and the
yeah yeah no we can't we can't Sophia
first of all you'd look like you have a
wet mop on your head this is that it
another pet peeve I have she's heinous
you're such an [ __ ] is okay it's when
we're doing laundry
and my clothes are wet
you don't put mine in the dryer to take
mine out if you need to use it so you
leave my wet clothes sitting in a
mountain wait on top of the water when
was the last time we've lived together
for me to do that to you
but I'm addressing when we did live
together
I think you're gonna just be relieved at
the fact that I will be the first one
I'm making you coffee every morning
because this girl texts me and goes do
you have any extra coffee and she just
comes to my apartment and takes a
leftover coffee that I would probably
drink because I have a coffee addict
honestly our whole family thinks it's
going to end in complete disaster us
living together but I'm actually really
excited we're having our new girl
fantasy remember we've always wanted to
live like a New York apartment like
brick walls exposed pipes wow
it'll be great I'm excited for it um
plus we're also really close to Florida
yeah and we can visit little Scarlet in
Miami and whoop it up which by the way I
ever go back to Miami
yeah the LA oh my God you were a mess
the last time we were in Miami I have a
photo evidence
I'll call it of Sophia walking barefoot
in an alley next to a dumpster with no
shoes on and my feet were killing me
okay if anyone understands shitty heels
and they are actually peeling off the
skin you're not your toes
um yes I will take off my shoes you're
dirty but that but honestly
unfortunately this is the problem she
showed me that photo because that was
the last photographic evidence of me
with my phone before I decided to drop
it
and then I had spent all night till like
4 a.m on my boyfriend's phone my
friend's phone trying to track this
phone this guy stole it and turned it
off well when in Miami here's my goal
though I want to sort of Rebrand myself
when I move to a new city
I want to have more fun and I feel like
I always say this on the podcast that
I'm not fun and I don't let loose enough
and I'll have like two drinks and be
like oh I can't have a third because I'm
gonna get crazy or I'm gonna say
something and regret or kiss a stranger
which I do and I don't tell you till I'm
not pushing you to drink more or like go
crazy or more but just lay off it and
like loosen up so like heading about it
just if you don't want to do not do it
if you want to do it do it no no I want
to do it I want to be pushed
um you're like the opposite of my you
don't like to be pushed I can ask Carl
right now if you tell if you tell
Christine to have another cocktail she
goes
I want you to be the opposite of my
sponsor
encourage it encourage it to figure out
like your alcohol sponsor I'm I'm a
sober gopher I need someone to push me
to have fun I think and I feel like if
we're living together you're gonna say
Sistine we're going out I love how we're
going to a jazz club and I would say no
but if you're there I'm going that's
true we will but I think the city is
much easier to be social than it is to
be in LA because La no one leaves their
house I think I I think I'm too
embarrassed to actually ever show my
face in La again we've literally spent
no time there but why would you say that
you're embarrassed because
what happened at that event that we went
to recently in LA
oh that's pretty those only me only
would this happen too and you know
what's funny right when it happened the
first thing I thought of was this is
great content for the podcast you know I
saw it you're literally the opposite of
like Aurora from Sleeping Beauty you
know she calls animals and like
Cinderella they can whistle I call like
the animals that no one wants yeah for
example Sophie and I get invited to this
beautiful Ralph Lauren fashion show why
we're invited I'm not sure I'm not sure
but I'm not fighting it thank you so
much Ralph that was incredible the
outfits were great so after the show
they have this big dinner for all of the
guests and they sort of group everyone
based off of age and career so we were
obviously at like the young Hollywood
kids table we met so many nice people so
many great people I mean everyone there
is honest Grace and Jackson were awesome
yeah they're on like great TV shows and
they're in Euphoria just like cool
people I mean it's so fun to see like we
watch so much TV yeah so we see all
these people on the shows we fall in
love with them and then we're having
dinner with them and it's great so
Sophia and I are just sort of sitting
there like oh my God this is so cool and
we're trying to we're like friends but
because we're like apart and we're a
part of it now but we don't think we are
this is the funny thing we're not
feeling so out of body at these events
every time I hate it because they just
know what they're doing they go to these
events so often that like they're just
so cool
it's that's bold because we actually go
to a lot of these events the problem is
that we don't think we're cool enough to
be at these events we're too
uncomfortable we're too uncomfortable so
I'm at this event going like yeah like I
mean it's like cool outfit with these
cool people and then I just feel like a
total nerd and doorknob but it's the
thing is is that I'm not because they're
talking about Club that's what I know I
need to interrupt our conversation right
yes but they asked about the book so so
let me tell you what happened to me
we're sitting at this dinner very Glam
very beautiful cool people around us
we're trying to fit in we're trying to
you know act like one of them you know
and uh the fact that you were doing this
just you know the visual we're just
super like yeah we do this too we're
awesome and uh no
I
look over because I feel something hit
my shoulder
and I was like that's weird so I looked
down at my shoulder and it's a b
and I was like oh what are you doing
there little guy like that's not a
flower
um it stings me the bee stung me and
everyone around at the table was like oh
my God like oh my God we're sitting
shoulder to shoulder like it could have
easily jumped on me there were 400
people there I was the one person to be
decided to just lay on and it stung me
and everyone's freaking out they're like
oh my God are you okay oh my God does it
hurt and I'm still trying to play it so
cool but like I like I plan this video
we got it we got a premises sistine's
allergic to bees very allergic to these
and I don't know if we ever told the
story about her the bee that when she
was laughing so hard with her
ex-boyfriend that it stung her in the
back of the throat I swallowed a bee so
this is my next interaction with the
beat at a fashion event she's like
traumatized and so again these people
are there a beast lands on my shoulder
stings me you see the sting there it's
massive and I'm just looking down at it
and I'm like hey so sorry I know you're
talking to
um you know Cole Sprouse right now but
um a beach stung me and she was like
what I was like yeah and I'm just trying
you guys and I know my head I'm like oh
[ __ ] and she's you know Sophia please
and they've had two glasses of wine
because I know I'm cool I brought the
ruffler she's like she's like being over
pounding drinks just to be comfortable
we were waiting by we were the last row
to like get the burgers because we got
the Revival and burgers were really good
so we're pounding these drinks waiting
for our purse and she's like Sophia hey
can you take out this singer well also
everyone so let me just preface this
everyone's freaking out right just so
much prefacing and my shoulder is
throbbing and it's like literally
pulsating and it's bright red I'm
sitting next to Mr McDreamy what's his
face um James Marsden James Marston's
next to me I'm like hey James check this
out he's like Jesus Christ
yeah so again I'm trying to play it so
cool and everyone's like oh my God this
is what I knew I sold it everyone was
like oh my God she's like is not even
reacting she's like so chill about it I
was like yeah I'm just a cooler side
freaking out so then I lay Sophia I'm
like the surgeon can you take the
stinger out I go my nails are really
long so I'm like absolutely not waiting
for someone to pick up like tweezers or
something or like you know you have to
use papers so like that because if you
squeeze it you squeeze and then a minute
but me thinking I'm a surgeon now I'm
like yeah guys I got this I squeeze the
Venom in it she literally pushed it in
so deep it came out a week later it came
out I was like well I guess I'm
she looked like the hunchback of Notre
Dame and so I asked him I was like do
you just have some like Neosporin or
something and like uh we were sitting
next to these these lovely people and
this he this guy pulls out in a giant
ice cube and just like sticks it on my
shoulder and I was like melting all over
my dress staining and I'm like this is
great this is exactly the impression I
wanted to leave thank you for your ice
thank you for the not Neosporin thank
you for pushing it in wow really like
come on yeah and I'm like are you good
eating some french fries and then that
was the night but you know what I
learned so I researched this because
bees mosquitoes they love me they do
they really love me and it actually has
to do with the acid levels on your skin
really they're attracted to certain skin
types
you don't have like acidic skin no
whatever that sometimes but you have you
get bit way more than I do spiders you
get bit by other I get bit by mosquitoes
you get bit more excuse me get bit by
spiders bees
X's men
I attract
pain I really there's meant
bears are Galactica I get all of it I
really do and honestly I think um I
wouldn't want it any other way it's a
great story it has a content for you
guys but I'm just traumatized I really
am yeah that hurt you recently too
actually
on the dock oh wait this is okay I we
want to translate let's translate uh
what's the word transition transition
she says she's a reader I haven't done
this in three months I'm getting like
again
so we all love bedtime stories bedtime
stories bad guys stories wait where'd
you sleep
[Music]
and we're back and then we're awake so
we are gonna do a bedtime story and this
is actually a story about Sistine
hurting me
um but it's funny because it's funny now
but I I'm actually really still bitter
about it because no one believes me I
feel like you started that really wrong
I did not do this to hurt you I did this
to have adventure with you and you hurt
yourself
no I'll tell you why here goes
so we have a doc in Florida my parents
have this like wide Dock and it has
beautiful fish that go under it and
turtles anyone else barracudas sharks
and catfish apparently bite you or sting
you so there are some bad things in the
water yeah we've seen frequently yeah so
Sistine and I are sitting on the dock
and we are just enjoying the night or
like it's Sunset right and there's
nothing in the water that we can see and
Sistine goes
I know I've touched the water and I tell
her I'm like wow the water feels
incredible and for some reason this
chick goes we gotta jump off and I said
let's we got strip down and jump off and
Sophia goes no what if someone sees and
I said that's the point and I always I
want Skinny Dip when it's bright it was
yeah it was bright yeah it was bright if
people would see us
um but I was like no maybe we can do it
with our clothes she goes go go go do it
and I was like no I really don't want to
do it and the thing was to see and I
hate this about her is that she almost
she makes she has this weird way of me
he feels so guilty for saying no to her
Jedi mind trick it's like if I asked her
to jump off the dock she didn't want to
and she said no I said come on she's
like shut up no I truly believe I've
actually mastered the art of convincing
people to do anything yeah I was I'm
very good at it so I go you know what
sistine's right maybe I should jump off
we should live life live life I said
what a great story this will be come on
Sophia we'll swim back to the shore
it'll be a great time guys there are
sharks barracudas and catfish and
everything else in that water but I
surveillance the area but she thinks she
surveillance it enough for us to be safe
so we jump off
and of course while jumping off I
realized we didn't put like bladder top
yeah but we said oh we would just swim
back to shore yeah my mom comes out and
she goes what do you do and I go and I
said living life
big things
mom join us we're young adults we're
free we're not really we're gonna swim
to shore she goes no no you actually
can't right now you're gonna get cut on
your feet like it's really really sharp
over there like you cannot swim to shore
you have to go up on the dock and I go
[ __ ] okay
um and so I'm freaking out she goes you
don't know what's in the water and she's
stressing me out since he's just Leisure
is she screaming like I see a shadow
yeah freaking out and I'm freaking out
so what I do is I see that there is the
latter so what you do when you're on a
dock you like pick up the ladder and it
drops down you like hook it back and you
pick it up and it drops down but I had
to reach up because it was hooked on and
instead of it coming down I had to pull
myself up literally like I was in
Cliffhanger I hate that I just use that
reference actually you know when you're
sometimes they'll pull up no you know
when you're in times of panic and then
you just get the Superstar strength yeah
that was you guys it was like me doing a
pull-up and I I have no upper body
strength I would like to say my point of
view I'm still in the water and I look
up and I just see ass in my face
um you're so welcome to see my ass
in your face
no okay but no so basically with all my
adrenaline and I'm freaking out I pull
myself up and while I'm pull up I feel
like literally the heart like the worst
scratches and like I'm getting
demolished by this rotten really was
rotten it was gross it was not like a
new ladder it was a used it was Rusty
yeah getting scratched and I get up I'm
just not sure how I didn't break but if
she drops the lottery
my legs are gushing with blood
everywhere everywhere my arms my legs
blood everywhere and I'm so pissed and
freaking out and I start having a panic
attack and this is the thing I might be
a little bit boy that cries wolf you're
such a hypochondriac Sophia gets a
sniffle she's like it's mono I get like
a hip problem my cancer she has a
headache she's like I'm dying of brain
cancer like she always thinks the worst
I just I have a fear of I don't know if
anyone else has this fear I just don't
want to miss something and then sudden
my life Turns Upside Down and I didn't
catch it soon enough like I've seen so
many horror stories and just I read too
much about it and it freaks me out but I
just had read a story about a girl that
was in a lake or B trying to throw her
if she was she got a cut and it got
super infected that she like died or she
knows she had to amputate
I was so much he's in the hot tub like
this hanging out I'm bleeding hanging
out and I'm like I can't I'm gonna die
but you did read an article that the
next day this is the thing my mom and
sister get so upset with me they're like
actually you're being really annoying
they were upset you are annoying they
they said I wasn't all that no you said
I don't know but you are I'm not you do
this all the time so why wouldn't we be
like you guys shut your mouth I said I
was gonna die an infection they said I'm
not this is the thing and they shut me
up because they were so pissed off at me
genuinely because I just wanted to have
fun and you ruined the fun look at this
by bleeding they all they all said I was
insane they all said I was being over
dramatic guess what I read all right
here it goes no and they all apologized
after I didn't apologize for [ __ ] there
was a code red article sent to everyone
in Palm Beach and it said Sophia's blood
is in the water code red yes
co-red emergency
a release from the town said the
saltwater quality sampling on Tuesday
found
enterocoli bacteria which normally
inhabit the intestinal tracts of human
and animals which may cause human
disease infections and rashes and
basically it said fecal matter was in
the water we weren't allowed to swim in
the water that week because it had
infectious diseases so tell me this if I
jumped off the talk that week got
scrapped let me ask you a question and
then swam I would have had my legs let
me ask you you would have to carry you
around all over the city
I'd give you a peg leg like a pirate did
you learn a lesson at least from this no
you learned the lesson that I might not
always be wrong so this is my bedtime
story is
I was right no this bedtime story is you
are an infection in my life because you
itch me you irritate me you need to let
loose and have more fun yeah okay you
got a little blood yellow blood on you
all right whoa whoa I need to have more
fun
you literally just said you don't have
fun anymore and that I need to make you
more fun
you
Scott did she just say she needs to be
more fun take your finger out of my face
did you see you saying check your damn
finger get out of my face you were the
one so she's the party pooper yeah this
is why I love this poop in the water
that's giving us infections
I wish a barracuda called right up your
ass I really do I really do next time
this is why I love this podcast why
because we bottle this [ __ ] in and it
just comes right out
when we're taping every single day every
single time so you guys
that was our comeback episode we really
we we really
um are quite I've got to say Rusty um
yeah this probably wasn't our most
organized episode but I had fun and I
hope you guys had fun listening to it
and I'm so happy to be back we're gonna
try to get these episodes out regularly
every Tuesday that is our goal for you
guys and we've just missed you and we
love you and thank you for still
following us and supporting us it's been
the best time ever it has been and we
missed you and we're really really
thankful for people that stuck around
for three months and waited yeah I'm
really coming back and it's me better
than ever and really excited for this
next step so we will see you next
Tuesday bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]